good morning Millennials and welcome
back to the chose happy Wednesday it is
hump day so don't forget to hump someone
you love and speaking of girlies that I
love and would love to get my hands on
in terms of humping you won't but you
won't it's Jackie oh hey Jax how you
doing darn good happy to be back with my
girly swirly turdy Luke girly release
I think maybe that'll be my next single
maybe our twirly Lou next no turdy Lou
is so taken off and the more I like go
out and meet toasters last night we did
a meet and greet for spritz the more I
need to like you don't even understand
ever I was like hi Turney everyone it is
I understand I know I understand the
feeling of being compelled to like call
someone a nickname LARP it up like I I
love that for you guys it's Larry has
honestly she's outgrown the show like
she's literally the biggest celebrity
I've ever met yeah she's she'll be doing
her own meet and greet soon literally
she's going on tour I heard she's
starting like a rival canned cocktail
company I heard she's starting like a
rival Hair Care brand it's gonna be
bigger than Beyonce I heard she's
starting a rival podcast oh I didn't
hear that I heard she's like singing
about starting a podcast with her
husband oh they don't have a format yeah
it's going to be called yeah it's all
about like birdie Lou and what's it
about Ben and charity Lou no I thought
it would be Dirty Lou and it's about
like sex
love it trademark trademark
um we've got a great show today because
it's Wednesday which is always just like
a good day and also it's like a
Wednesday that feels like a Thursday
because we're operating on a short week
because it's Memorial Day weekend and
the summers are kind of beginning we
haven't even like spoken about that I
know we could start wearing white jeans
I wore white pants last week I felt as
though it was close enough I wore cream
colored pants but also that's kind of
like in style right now is like creamy
beige shoes sad beige so I don't know
where that lies with like the fashion
rule right like where do the trend and
the rule kind of intersect but I think
like paper white jeans you know yeah
yeah like yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
that has to wait until after Memorial
very Nantucket yeah luckily I don't have
a pair of maternity paper white jeans I
just have my cream trousers well I have
some wet jeans for my big fat days I
still have to shop in your closet you do
I have so much stuff waiting for you I'm
so excited so that was fun and what also
is going to be fun is we have to your
toasters today and we have an update and
it is an update remember when Chelsea
Handler came on our show and she did a
bunch of um advice with us yeah it was a
girl who had written in about a virgin
yes okay and it's really interesting
because we you and I gave very different
advice than Chelsea
yo
you'll um have to wait to the end
episode to see Whose advice she took and
how it Panda and how it panned out it's
very interesting um wow not you with the
click bait to continue listening to the
episode listen and for me to continue
performing episodes yeah I'm just like I
see everyone online is constantly
clickbaiting and I feel like we're a
little too real like we caught we come
on and we're like hey new episode today
it's not our best like I'm gonna start
clickbaiting the out of the show
okay we got bills to pay I know but like
we are so we're talented women I think I
agree but we are not skilled in the
realm of clickbait no and the one time
we tried to click bait we got
roasted they were like how could you do
this I don't know how people handled you
said it was gonna be this but it was
really this it was like yeah I'd be
holding everyone this accountable no
it's like you we said it was going to be
this and it ended up being that it's
called clickbait we gotcha so yeah we're
a little too authentic for our own good
yeah we could stand to be a little more
like smoking mirrors right there's too
much substance on this show we're too
authentic
we've got to dial it back turdy yeah I'm
gonna start lying or let's just say have
a conversation like that's like bogus
but we could like click bait it you know
okay
see I can't even come up because I'm so
authentic I understand
me crazy tell me about you Jax what's
new with you Jax is good we're recording
the redheads today finished the book
last night really good and then I was
reading the author's note at the end
because the book is advika and the
Hollywood wives and it's about
this woman who marries like a fancy big
old Hollywood producer and then she
starts to do research onto his Ex-Wives
and in the authors no the author was
just like writing what inspired the
story how she was watching an old season
of Real Housewives of Beverly Hills one
day and like the it was an old season so
she was just watching this couple with a
husband like wasn't really interested in
the wife at best Kelsey Grammar critical
and what I need to think and then
there's a few more clues okay and then I
figured it out and um then it was so far
in the past that they've since gotten
divorced and he's gotten remarried since
to his fifth wife and she was just
thinking to herself like the fifth wife
like doesn't know at this point like and
so that's kind of what inspired the
story who has had fifth Five Wives
it's so right there
is it a current housewife no but she's
relevant and he's relevant and his new
marriage is relevant he being the
husband not Kelsey Grammar no
um I don't know
David Foster oh doll oh my God that's
actually really good that's so funny I
have quite literally never once in my
goddamn life red
the author's acknowledgments except in a
celebrity Memoir because I want to see
if they think like any other celebrities
and sometimes I'm just like curious
because like I wrote a book and I always
want to see like do I have the same book
agent as like any of these people
because actually my book agent has a lot
of like top tier clients yeah I feel
like even on a regular fiction book you
should read the thank yous and
acknowledgments because there's like
industry people in there like they'll
cite their agency in their book at like
it could be some Insider information it
could have been people that you worked
with maybe I just like once I'm done
with the book even if I loved it so
here's the thing if I loved the book I
don't want to kind of break the fourth
wall and like learn more about the
author I'm good and if I hated the book
get this Kindle away from me yeah so I
really don't like to read the
acknowledgments so much so that in my
book I actually didn't even write
acknowledgments damn that's harsh turdy
Lou I know I that it kind of is
something I'd like a little bit regret
because it really are I really have some
such a wonderful Foundation but I
remember like it was such a laborious
process writing the book I'm like I'm
not writing more but also your book is
an acknowledgment yeah if you're not in
the book like why would you but you're
gonna be in the acknowledgment it's not
like you were like doing a show in your
book and then here's the real me
acknowledging everyone who made it
happen like the whole time you're
speaking your truth why do we need a a
chapter at the end of truthness of
Charities no okay thank you for making
me feel and feel better about it they
were like do you want to write
acknowledgments and my own experience
with reading at that point was like I
hated the acknowledgments I'm like no I
want to give substance I don't want
there to be extra pages in the back of
like crap like I want the book to be one
and too substantial for her own good too
real I'm literally Simon van campen I am
real you're no because you're too real I
am too real Justice for assignment van
campen also another interesting thing
about Andy's book that things keep
coming to me I actually wanted to share
a funny anecdote with you because at my
book club someone else was reading it
and we were just talking about it and I
said like it wasn't the most substantial
book I don't think he necessarily like
had something to say but what I always
have found was interesting about Andy's
book is his level of celebrity is just
so intriguing it's like you know on a
daily basis he's gonna interact in a
deep and meaningful way with 10 famous
people and really famous and so his best
friend's name is John Hill
so we get to text one day from John Hill
who he texts every day he hosts radio
Andy with him of the trailer of Jonah
Hill's new movie and Andy responded and
question mark like why the like he
didn't care and then he realized a few
hours later that John never responded to
him so he went back to his text messages
and until it was Jonah Hill who texted
him the trailer to his new movie and
Andy was like so dismissive being like
and
and then Andy had to be like oh my God I
thought it was my man and then Jonah
Hill never responded like very funny
little things like that that I find so
interesting but what I was going to say
is speaking of the van kempins and he
like really loves Alex McCord like he
really wanted her when they were talking
about Roni Legacy when they were talking
about ugt he like really reached out to
her and she's very like she is such a
new Happy kind of Clean Slate life
living in Australia and she the fact
that she even did the ultimate girls
trip in Morocco was a huge thing but she
was like she was offered Legacy that
makes sense but she would have to move
back right and it's just not enough for
her good thing she said no because it
didn't even happen imagine moving back
and the show doesn't happen yeah but it
just gave me a lot of respect for Alex
McCord yeah and that was one of my
takeaways during the pandemic when I
re-watched um Roni like the early
Seasons so good everyone the audience
included about the women like in the
beginning they were so mean to Alex
McCord simply because she was like kind
of weird and lived in Brooklyn like that
was it yeah she didn't really do it
she's never a villain reality TV has
really evolved like one like you could
never really gang up on someone like
that anymore without a reason no no
without like being totally like canceled
yourself yeah they don't treat people
like that anymore like Sheena the way
that they yeah like that would never fly
now
so we're all changing and growing
growing we do it every day we're growing
in the evening and even when we play and
if we show ones
it's a good song from our childhood
what's like your favorite Nursery
Limerick rhyme thing oh such a good
question I have so many on the tip of my
tongue these days I love Doremi that's
one of my favorites because it's easy to
play on all those kid instruments what
about Ring Around the Rosie no I don't
with it you don't no but it's also
like for kids who are running right
around the rosy ring right and that
sounds like a nightmare no and that's
just like I have a toddler a tinfit
right a tin fan he's not running nowhere
no apparently the word for rolled age
like the colloquial word that we're all
saying is he's a taby a toddler baby
I don't think it's cute like let's not
make up new words but it's confusing as
you established like right he's in a
transitional phase okay that's what I
would say okay oh also I was like gonna
follow up with you by eodia I was hoping
maybe after this we could like maybe
hang out with world yeah he's got a busy
day and he would love for you to join us
I have some free time that I think I'll
donate to to rolled I love that for you
but I am also have recording redheads in
the afternoon last time I recorded
redheads you were hanging out with him
without me you remember yes of course
I'd love to come on redhead's day I do
maybe it's just like we're always
recording redheads always working on our
passions which is so important yeah so
what else did I want to share with you
before we dived in I cannot recall I
finished last night I'm all caught up on
somebody somewhere the Bridget Everett
show like it's good I've decided you
know okay good oh my God and yesterday
was such a annoying day when I
got home like I was exhausted from the
meeting because they just wanted to
watch my show and eat my chili
HBO Max you know Max you have to
download a new app
they never said that they never said
that I'm trying to be optimistic about
the Rebrand because I know like a
Rebrand a lot of money goes into it a
lot of time like people's jobs are a
mistake you know it's make or break and
I want to be supportive because I think
HBO Max has good content and they're
trying something new and I'm just like
trying to be there for them but they
need to make it easy for us so I will
say once again May 23rd was the big day
once I downloaded the new app which just
was such an inconvenience because my
chili was like already on my lap like I
was set up all of I was already logged
in and all of my like watch lists
continue watching like it was all like
back loaded but why couldn't they just
change the logo the logo upload a new
file it was such a it was such an
inconvenience I really like I can't
stress enough how inconvenienced I felt
damn so were you a Max in Easter last
night I was a fashionista and a Max and
Easter would you watch Bridget Everett
Bridget Everett yeah and then a little
bit of young Sheldon you know as a
palette cleanser before bed you're
obsessed I'm obsessed with young Sheldon
I'm I'm so happy that you have that
show that brings me piece like in a
while well they've also stopped
searching well just know like I am my
time is almost up with young Sheldon I
know they have many many seasons but
young Sheldon becomes like tween Sheldon
and that's your least favorite and he
gets like a hairy upper lip like I'm not
interested when young children are on TV
and then they go through that like
awkward like kind of ugly phase brand
Stark I I can't he's a confirm that he
has like that his transitional face is
ugly like some people no I'm sure it's
not always no I'm sure he's he's a good
looking kid like he's handsome it's not
like that I'm just not interested like I
find I had to live through that part of
life and it was difficult I really can't
watch it okay you know yeah like his
voice cracks like I'm just
okay
so it's a little harsh but it is harsh
but that's just like but it's like it's
your free time it's your entertainment
like you choose what you watch and it's
just it's definitely a preference of
mine I know I'm not saying ubiquitously
like kids at the age of 12 to 13 can't
act I just will not be supporting those
arts and do you only feel that way about
Boy actors correct uh yes it's only like
bothered you so far but I feel like you
haven't really experienced it well
Sheldon is a twin sister how's she doing
right I just I really don't like to
watch like the puberty phase of kid like
I just don't like it like it makes me
uncomfortable I can't really explain I
can't give any further information but
it just does okay we'll leave it at that
so I feel like we've click baited long
enough maybe we should dive into the
stories what do you think we should dive
into the stories because the stories are
storying again which I'm really grateful
for thanks to everyone who participated
in the news yesterday and made yourself
known and we have some really kind of
like sickening sponsors today so I'm
kind of excited about that so without
further Ado here are the past five
stories that you need to know
and today's episode is brought to you by
the Kardashians on Hulu season three we
are watching the all new season of the
Kardashians on Thursdays only on Hulu so
the first episode I believe is out
tonight there's so much hoopla there's
the girls are back together I'm so
excited I was just saying I needed a
pick-me-up show oh that's and this is it
I just been in season two and it was
such a wonderful experience and I'm so
excited for season three because they
brought the goods the world's most
famous matriarchy is back for the most
intimate look yet inside the family
Empire there is a lot of speculation on
what is going on between Courtney and
Kim there was like rumors before and
then this trailer that dropped I kind of
fed into that so we know there's drama
at the wedding dng the whole thing
there's a lot that happens this season
that I'm really excited to see you know
the businesses the sisterly bonds The
Sibling Rivalry the dating the Newfound
love family growth juggling business
motherhood all of that things all of
those things so we're going to see each
of the women up close and personal more
than ever as they evolve as what it
really means to be a Kardashians we've
got Chris we've got Courtney we've got
Kim we've got Chloe or as Andy Cohen
likes to call her Chloe we've got
Kendall and we've got Kylie we've got
positivity we've got light we've got
Sisterhood we've got friendship we've
got family you just love to see it I
feel like it's been a long time since
last season or maybe just like a lot has
happened in my life and a lot has
happened in their lives and even in a
trailer that dropped yesterday Chris is
like making a tote and she's like to the
worst year ever and I'm like what is she
referring to
is it Wednesday night yeah because I
have to know so don't miss season three
of the Kardashians new episodes are
dropping Thursdays only on Hulu today's
episode is also brought to you by the
real real we finally made it to Summer
and for all those events Beach weekends
weddings and everything in between
especially if you're saying yes to life
our go-to shopping destination is always
the realreal.com so the real real is the
largest and most trusted source for
authenticated luxury resale you'll find
everything from Gucci Prada air maze
ghani stodd so much more and it's all up
to 90 off of retail they have over 10
000 New pieces arriving every single day
so you are bound to find exactly what
you were looking for at the realreal.com
what's so exciting about the real reel
is like you know we're girls who love to
invest but you know my God we can only
invest so much so when we want designer
pieces the real real is always our first
place to go and what's so great about
kind of being an investor is cycling
through things like buying and selling
buying and selling so we sell a lot of
our stuff on the real real all the time
actually a Gucci bag sitting right there
that is uh waiting to be picked up by
the railroad so if you have an item to
consign the real offers a full service
experience from free virtual
appointments and at home pickups to
direct shipping and drop-off services at
their retail locations sorry I just
realized I did say that you could have
that bag yeah but I see that you're
selling it now well what what it's not
entirely right for me and I'm not going
to give you as good of a price as you're
going to get on the real real the thing
is I bring things in I have to send them
back out that's the the beauty of the
real real so one of the easiest ways to
shop or consign is through the real real
app download it now plus visit
therail.com and use code toast at
checkout for 20 off that's the
realreal.com using Code toast for 20 off
not me like literally using my own code
on a weekly basis probably that's
probably the most of all of our sponsors
that of the code that I personally use
obsessed such a great resource like if
you love fashion if you want to get
things at a discount and also you want
to make sure that they're the real deal
like they do all that vetting right you
don't have to you know take a chance
terms apply code toast for 20 off our
first story so we got some podcasting
news today first podcasting news our
automatic oh he's on call her daddy the
episode dropped last night I started
watching it this morning while I was
getting ready I made it about 24 minutes
in so I have a lot ahead of me because
it's two hours I watched 35 minutes in
okay so we know about the same amount
and everything that I watched so far
like I already knew because I think Alex
is really trying I don't think all of
her audience watches Bravo and doesn't
know exactly what happened so a lot of
it is stuff that we just saw on the
finale or that Ariana said I don't Watch
What Happens live so like or just like
giving context and background I will say
I don't think I'm the target demo for
the interview but I do think it was like
a really smart thing because everyone is
now like scrambling for people who are
into pop culture but who don't know
they're like where do I start what do I
watch peacock made like a watch list
here are all the episodes from all 10
seasons that you need to watch in order
to be caught up
um so that was like a smart tactic
although I don't like I was finding it
redundant just because not one thing
goes on in better purples I'm like a
loser who doesn't know that I don't know
about right I think though in the whole
two hour interview I there are stories
and tidbits that we don't know yet maybe
we'll be finding out on the reunima
chairs tonight like one thing I saw
which is the headline that's coming
right that's forthcoming what is it just
that Tom and Raquel had sex in their
guest room no while she was sleeping
next door like Tom left her bed went
into the guest room America was had sex
with our cat and then I think I mean
that's disgusting but the other
one that I saw was that when they when
Tom and Tom were in New York and they
were on watch weapons live like and
remember Schwartz was like being so
weird they were like talking about he
was covering his mouth the whole time
Raquel was in New York at in Tom
Sandoval's hotel room waiting for him so
they're like talking about Raquel and
Schwartz and like Schwartz knows that's
why he like couldn't talk yeah oh I
didn't I thought that he knew but not
like the part that Raquel is in New York
but made it even more awkward but I was
watching speaking of like clickbait and
some of the questions in the trailer
weren't really titillating I'm excited
to get the answers like one Alex is like
the band's not good like what were you
no like what like thanks God you know if
I could ask Ariana one question I would
say like like this is what I would say
for years like you supported that him in
the band like and it's not that great
well actually yesterday I don't know if
this is like a spoiler but the good guys
interviewed Chris and Dodie and I gave
them a list of questions and one of my
questions was like you were in a
relationship with this person for many
many years
is Tom Sandoval like the person who we
know right now is that always always
been or like has the show made him this
monster because like honestly Rock I
mean um Ariana and Kristen like you both
dated him for many many years did you
not see what we saw or is that like a
new development where you you blinded by
his charm like what was it and uh I'm
waiting to see their response okay great
good question so I'm curious to hear her
response on that yeah and then also she
had asked like do you feel like you
turned a blind eye and I I feel like she
did in the trailer it's I think she says
yes but it could have been yes to a
different question but
yes so I feel like there is a lot in the
interview that will provide even like
more color and context to the situation
but I didn't have time to finish it this
morning and I went to bed early last
night because yeah our girl was tired
the
um
a lot of people were speculating that it
wasn't going to be Ariana who was the
guest because Alex has kind of like
teased Vanderpump and a lot of people
thought it was maybe going to be
Schwartz or Sandoval or Raquel now I
don't I think her audience like would
have been they're like very like female
empowerment audience I don't think they
would have appreciated like her giving a
platform to the other woman but having
said that like we have not heard
from Raquel I know she's in a facility
and she's taking care of her mental
health which is of most important but at
some point I do believe she'll speak
what do you think she's going to do I
don't know but that will be an
interesting interview I honestly like
I'm glad Ariana got on it because all
these amazing things are happening for
Ariana but when people had been
speculating that it was Raquel like I
was actually a little bit more excited
because we've heard from Ariana at this
point we know everything yeah and just
like more interested like there's gonna
be I would love to hear from Schwartz
Schwartz I thought oh I guess he went on
Watch What Happens live he's just like
chaos but also Watch What Happens like
rapid fire questions it's not like life
sit down and talk about your feelings
yes
yeah but I I don't know in what format
we're gonna hear from Raquel or maybe we
won't we'll just see her on the next
season
I don't know either would you have her
on the toast 100 okay so maybe to Ashley
Jacobs like we could do anything so true
let's manifest it oh yeah
yeah
that's like that is the next thing I'm
looking forward to I feel like at this
point we've kind of exhausted and the
reunions right with the reunions watch
weapons live everyone having their own
podcast we've kind of exhausted this
side I kind of want to hear the other
side not that I think it's going to
change my mind or anything but that's
interesting yeah
I I feel like she could also go and call
her daddy yeah
I don't know if Alex would do that I
feel like Alex has like for a while
there was kind of like having like the
villains villains Jamie Lynn Christine
even though to me she was never the
villain of that right right me neither
um yeah I like that like I think those
conversations are more interesting yeah
though this I think is very interesting
and it is two hours and usually the
episodes are not that long so I'm sure
there's so much meat right and I think
the reason why it is so long is the
whole thing of like giving context which
I actually think is smart although it's
not for me
like giving backgrounds
even like I think it's necessary for a
lot of people yeah
so I'm gonna continue watching and I
look forward to learning more yeah you
also see this Ariana
um like sofa thing no so there were like
Paparazzi pictures of Ariana finally
moving out and she posted on her story
like finally moving out with boxes and
stuff and then it turned out that she's
like not moving out it was like part of
a brand partnership for sofa like
financial planning app okay because I
saw a headline Tom Sandoval leads the
country and Ariana pretends to move out
and I was like what she it was
pretending but like I like get that coin
oh for sure
but like also could he move out maybe
they could financially plan you out of
your house right or like we said last
week uh Airbnb somebody VRBO some
company like give Ariana a house for a
couple months till she can like get her
together and move out yeah maybe
she doesn't want to move out of her
house like you ruined my life I'm also
moving out of my house so she should
change the locks while he's gone she
should
she shed I hope they talk about that
yeah and I think they will talk about
that because they were already talking
about how like it's weird that they had
to go home together that night right
right and the fact that like Tom
Sandoval was saying to Sheena like we
bought a house as a Band-Aid and Ariana
was like well that was news to me I
thought we bought a house two like
further our relationship
our connection yeah
so yeah
so um what's the other podcasting news
the other podcasting news is our next
story okay
and it's another headline from the Jonas
Brothers on armchair experts yes because
I didn't realize all three brothers went
on together because I don't listen to
the podcast but honestly like click
baiting it's working influenced and I'm
loving listening to podcasts while I'm
getting ready I know it's so much better
than listening to music
no especially if you're watching it's
not so much better if you're watching it
sounds so much better but it's also a
nice experience yes
but anyway so Joe Jonas said he was so
jealous when Nick got the voice gig
instead of him that he cried his eyes
out Joe Jonas listening to Landslide Joe
Jonas revealed he cried out of jealousy
after finding out his younger brother
Nick Jonas was going to be a judge on
The Voice during this episode of the
armchair expert with Dax Shepard he
explained that he found out the news
while watching Fleetwood Mac play
Landslide at MSG in March 2019. he said
hello emotional it was the most
picturesque setting I was so jealous I
cried my eyes out to Landslide the
singer
said it was bittersweet of course
because I'm super happy for him but I'm
also bummed because I want that
gig Joe had served as a coach on the
Australian voice for one season in 2018
which had brother Kevin chiming in that
he was more qualified than Nick to do
the job he said I just enjoyed the job
so I was like what the but Nick
crushed it and you know it was great
Nick went on to work as a voice coach on
Seasons 18 and 20 of the singing
competition before being replaced by Ari
six so awkward so awkward like to even
speak it like I feel like if let's say
we were both up for a job and you got it
I was like devastated never once in my
life would I admit that I would say that
I'd just be like and I really I would be
happy but like I would be feeling both I
would be like no it was meant to be like
Jackie was amazing at it but is it not
healthier to admit it if you really felt
that it would be weird if you were
actually devastated and you didn't voice
that no it is but like it's weird
yeah I guess it's just so weird it's
weird to be in like such competition
like yeah it's so popular you know what
I mean like because I really can't
imagine a situation like I could imagine
a situation where you get to do
something that like I think is so cool
but really can't ever like imagine
crying that it wasn't me I know I know
we're different it's obviously different
yeah no like this feels so strange to me
especially because I'm actually shocked
that Nick got the job over Joe I feel
like in terms of like technicality and
like being able to help musicians I
guess maybe Nick is better suited but in
terms of personality and also just like
I don't know I really feel like Joe is
the lead singer of the band you know I
feel like that's actually been kind of
finalized in the last few years you
disagree I disagree you think Joe Nick
is I I think it's still like 50 50 but I
think the fact that Nick did like solo
work and was really successful and like
Joe was still just like in a band again
and like I feel like Nick is more
qualified for the job by the way I'm not
disagreeing I think qualified yes and a
better choice like overall like I do but
I would have thought if the two were up
or something like Joe would have gotten
it to me like Joe is the more famous One
Joe is the more charismatic personality
one Nick is like and I feel like that's
almost been like an intentional thing
that he's done over the last few years
is become much more like
the leader of the music not the leader
of the band do you know what I mean
yeah but I don't know I feel like if Joe
had been a judge on The Voice
it wouldn't have been a strong a choice
oh that's so funny I disagree then Nick
but maybe that just goes back to me at
my core I will always be a Joe girl like
since I loved the Jonas Brothers in
Middle School like I was always a joke
girl so maybe
Joe and I see them through the lens of
Nick like I was a Nick girl
interesting and maybe I just can't even
see them right no we're definitely
biased even though I think in recent
years I'm definitely a Kevin girl I
think the whole world is Kevin girls I
think part of growing up is like
realizing like it's not Nick versus Joe
like it's just Kevin it's always been
Kevin and it always will be Kevin and
the other two can fight it out for the
voice share but like Kevin's coming home
for dinner right no Kevin is like the
part-time rock star part-time you know
New Jersey suburb dad and like we just
we have quite literally no choice but to
stand and I don't want a choice no
because I like this one there is no
choice I like this one choice I like it
a lot like I look alike because I like
it
a greeting so that does sound like an
interesting interview that all three of
them were on sounds like a lot of people
in the room because there's two hosts
and three guests but um
this is good I'd like to see the Jonas
Brothers like we've never seen them
before opening up being vulnerable
talking about like there are just like a
lot of elements of their work life that
are are weird and awkward obviously the
breakup and when they talk about it like
they talked about it in their
documentary which was like really honest
I think that really endeared people to
them even more Beyond just like liking
their music
um and things like this I think are
really good for them because
sibling competition like that's
relatable everybody has like most people
have siblings and I think there's a lot
of really interesting just like human
elements to their work and like owning
like the jealousy could never be me but
it's so brave yeah but it's crazy that
they're able to still work like I know
it broke them up once
but it feels like they're really
heightened levels of jealousy like I
don't know what
like I feel like they have people and
plans in place for when like things go
you know in like their teams like have
to communicate like oh you can't put
them up like it's a very delicate dance
and it's working right now yeah but you
want to know why I think I think like
when they broke up the first time like
they were so famous they thought they
would just be fine forever even if they
weren't a band they were still so famous
and like things got good for Nick for a
little bit and
it just it wasn't gangbusters everyone
is making fun of me because I've been
using that word all week but I think
they thought they were at a level of
Fame like whether they were in the band
or not like they would still always be
okay money Fame success wise and after a
few years like it wasn't like that like
they all kind of faded and so I think
they realized okay we can either not be
in the man at all and live this kind of
like not lesser but less successful life
or we put up with these Dynamics we know
that it's a part of it and we work
through it
but what will be the bad and we'll be
this level and they they're back to
they're so famous now and I think they
just know that they have to deal with
these weird things yeah or it's back to
you know the sad days yeah
good for them yeah I feel like there's
just like a level of acknowledgment now
like we're dealing with this
and I think that's healthy I think so
too
but it's weird
are you ready for our next story yeah
speaking of
competition show judges Katy Perry wants
to quit American Idol after being shown
as the nasty judge a report says per the
Daily Mail so Katy Perry reportedly
wants to step down as a judge on
American Idol because she feels
misrepresented by the show per the Daily
Mail the pop star believed she has been
repeatedly quote thrown under the bus by
producers who she feels have edited the
show to make her appear to be the nasty
judge the singer who has been part of
the show for the last six seasons has
been criticized multiple times in the
last few months for comments she has
made to contestants we've even reported
on some of them like the mom shaming you
know that she laid on the table too much
um you wearing too much glitter you were
I think someone's outfit Choice he had a
glitter bomb on the stage and so I think
she feels like they're they're
manufacturing it because there is should
always be a Simon Cowell and they're
kind of shoe warning her into that
position but I do want to say though I
want to say one thing that like
the last couple of months of episodes
are live
so there's no real editing at play here
but I can definitely see what she's
saying
in terms of like the audition episodes
and like the Hollywood week those are
all edited so there's definitely an
element of that having said that I don't
know if you know what Katy Perry's
financial situation is like she is
making 25 million dollars a year to be
on the show so like if they're making
you look like a little harsh like okay
yeah I agree there's also you know some
people are uh sources saying that she's
not phased by the backlash and this has
been a roller coaster season with a lot
of great talent she's just doing her job
um so who knows but I but I do feel like
in looking at the news entertainment
news every day like there is this
narrative that Katie said this on the
show but I oh
I don't think there's really anything
wrong with that no me neither but every
time I saw those stories I was like oh
that's weird that she said that mean
thing why wouldn't producers take that
out it's like literally so easy
right and it was clearly like a Mis
misspeaking situation she's not like a
person with ill will yeah towards a
contestants right so they just kind of
like hung her out yeah and like the show
isn't about like exposing the judges no
it's like a family-friendly it's a nice
show right so I I feel like maybe they
are making her be this like harsher
judge but I do think that's fine I do
think it's strong when like there's
three really different personalities and
one person's gonna say hard truths now
the two things that we just cited like
aren't hard truths they're just like I
mean the mom thing I I genuinely think
like that was just her Miss speaking it
was like a a bad joke fell flat like I
don't think that's really bad and the
other thing like that's her attempt at
giving critique like you're critiquing
someone's performance and part of a
performance is what you wear and how you
do your hair and the lights like these
are all things that factor into
performance she's a person who has
extensive experience performing and I
like hate when when when the people who
are supposed to be judges it's like a
new like new very modern Progressive
like we're not going to critique people
like some of the Simon Cowell used
to say judge right some of the
Simon Cowell used to say like of course
would never fly
um you know I actually just saw a clip
like a compilation of like mean things
he said is like I just heard a cat die
like you know you would never say that
but I will say that's why a lot of
people tuned in 40 million right that is
you know they're you're you're supposed
to be critiquing and now it's just like
oh you need some work come back next
year how about just you stick like
that's what the job is so I don't think
there's really anything wrong with that
and the two examples we cited one I
think was genuinely like a mistake taken
out of context fell flat and the other
like maybe you should stop wearing them
and it's like if Katy Perry saying
you're wearing too much glitter maybe
you need to look in the mirror right
like she wants you to be like you know
versatile yeah when you've watched the
audition process what are the like
Vibes of the okay three judges when I
watch the audition process for Katie
like I never really thought she was like
villain Simon like hard truths I always
feel like she acts so weird around the
young guys like I I like that has been
from last season to the season she's
always like being so weird when there's
like a young good-looking guy she's like
oh well aren't you like for the
creepy that was my takeaway okay
that's that Luke to me is like snooze
Fest 2.0 like everything is great he's
very much like
puppy energy you know he's not going to
tell you you're bad
he's just gonna say you know come back
next year okay work on your pitch you
know he's not gonna
and then Lionel is this like wise old
well-respected grandpa
and is he nice yes
okay but he if he needs to critique he
will
got it well it sounds like none of them
are really making that much of an impact
no it's not like a Randy apollon
assignment even though I can't even
recall what like Paula's
disposition was and Randy's like I feel
like they were kind of similar it was
really just like the Simon yeah I think
Randy would
would say stuff if needed but Paula was
just like Paula yeah but I feel like the
show is doing really well with the
judges they have now I don't think I
don't I hope Katie I hope this isn't
real and her feelings aren't actually
her right 25 million dollars a year
right like crying to your money honestly
like say mean or stuff yeah right 25
okay they're
ugly
like we need assignment I know and I
feel like if any if there's a truth to
any of this I think she should lean into
it more lean into the Simon there is
something to be said about the success
of the voice where they never had any
sort of
you know dynamic between the judges all
the judges were just really sweet and
funny and the the show really played off
of the dynamic between the judges judges
it's like friends and and friendly
competitions so there's something to be
said about maybe those shows don't need
that for sure but American Idol is the
is the OG they don't need to go and copy
the voice now like they built a format
that really it's the blueprint and I
think Simon the Simon and they're being
a Simon is is key yeah no I don't
disagree so I think they should lean in
more but not into comments about laying
on the table yeah no like talk about the
singing right being like you sounded
pitchy you need work not the right song
for you no day job yeah don't quit your
Daydream well that's the opposite
message
but they should say that one's a
powerful they should say that to Ian
I love em do you know what Ian is short
for
you can guess it it's like so obvious
Ian Miller no
um
maybe I don't think of em as a prefix
think of it as a William yes is that
crazy carriages I never heard em as a
nickname for William that's so cute so
his name is William yeah oh my God not
that I would know that like in my
limited I watched one video but I'm glad
I do yeah
hey thanks for that Claudia you're
welcome are you ready for our next story
only if it's our next story that's
brought to you by Lululemon tis
Lululemon shorts were made to stretch
flex and support the infinite ways of
working out giving you the courage to
LEAP into something totally new and
unexpected so there's a ton of fabulous
shorts at Lululemon like the hottie hot
short the Wonder train short the pace
breaker short which are for men's
um and they have so many fabulous
qualities I'm going to tell you about
like the hottie hot short is a short
with a comfortable range of motion and
motion and a flattering fit they allow
you to Max your stride so you can move
freely and confidently lightweight
fabric help the lightweight Swift fabric
lets in airflow so you can move without
baggage they're designed to Wick away
sweat before you even notice that it's
there you can carry your Essentials with
two perfectly placed discreet Pockets
the Wonder train short or the short and
supportive stretch that keeps you dry
they're powered by the everlux fabric
the Wonder train collection manages heat
and sweat so you stay comfortable and
focused what I love about all the
products from Lululemon but especially
their shorts during summer time is you
know those nether regions the creases of
your thigh
the underbelly undercarriage they can
you know become accumulate they can
become hotbeds of
moisture moisture of sweat and wearing a
pair of shorts that's going to protect
you that's going to absorb that sweat
that sweat Wick fabric is really
important and Lululemon is a brand you
can trust I feel like everyone's always
going to Lululemon for their athleisure
so whether you're running around this
summer you know doing sports working out
or just running to the grocery store
wearing a pair of shorts that's going to
protect you is about most importance so
you can get into the Lululemon shorts at
lululemon.com I personally love the
hottie hot short it's great for a midday
running with rolled you know running
after world is a sweaty sweaty sport
it's a sport so get into Lululemon
shorts at lululemon.com today's episode
is also brought to you by ZipRecruiter
so if you were to start a new business
Jax what do you think you would start I
think I would start a business
um honestly like my dream would be like
an animal like Sanctuary that's so
beautiful but I wouldn't know where to
start no and you need to start with
amazing employees like the one you found
yeah so whether you're starting a new
business or growing one if you want to
be successful you need the most talented
people on your team and that's where
ZipRecruiter comes in and right now you
can try ZipRecruiter for free at
ziprecruiter.com toast now Jackie ask me
why should I let ZipRecruiter help me
hire for money business why should I let
tip recruiter hire me for my new
business why should you let ZipRecruiter
hire what yeah why should I let you know
I should oh why should you let super
recruiter hire for your new business
like I'm starting this new animal
sanctuary and I'm so glad you asked
because they're powerful matching
technology finds highly qualified
candidates for a wide range of roles if
you've got your if you've got your eye
on someone or maybe two people who would
be perfect for your job zip recruiter
actually lets you send them a personal
invitation so they are more likely to
apply to your job they also offer
attention grabbing labels that can speak
to your job flexible ability like if you
offer remote if you offer training if
you offer if it's an urgent position all
these little tags that people who are
looking for remote jobs are going to be
automatically drawn to your job and your
job listing will stand out more so let's
ZipRecruiter fill your roles with the
right candidates four out of five
employers who post on ZipRecruiter get a
quality candidate within the first day
see for yourself go to our exclusive
link which is ziprecruiter.com toast and
you will get ZipRecruiter for free so
that's ziprecruiter.com toast
ZipRecruiter the smartest way to hire
thank you our next story we're just
segueing with major Segways is some more
American Idol news because American Idol
2020 winner just Sam says she's back to
singing in New York City Subways she
says quote I was super embarrassed but
last month the musician began sharing
videos of herself singing in subway
stations on Instagram and recently
opened up about her journey since
winning the hit competition series
noting that she was quote super
embarrassed to let fans know that she's
back to busking so she posted a clip of
herself singing Aries Almost Is Never
Enough I don't know why I can't say
Ariana Grande when I can just say sorry
um and she explained her situation in a
since deleted caption but she said quote
back in 2021 I was super embarrassed to
be going back to the trains I didn't
want people to know that I legit needed
the money and I didn't want people to
know that it wasn't optional I was
disappointed in myself for allowing
myself to fall so low after winning Idol
but then I had to take it easy on me and
remember that I started my idol my
journey with Idol at 20 years old not
even knowing anything about Hollywood or
the music industry she added since then
I've learned so much and I've been able
to take my experiences and share them
with other artists in hopes that they
don't experience the same things that I
did when it comes to making it in this
life she reportedly noted that her
season of idol occurred in the middle of
covid and left her in a state of
uncertainty uncertainty about the future
but that she was ready and waiting for
whatever it was quote everyone wants to
know what happened and why this or why
that and I will answer those questions
someday but in the meantime I'll say
this I never expected to win but I did I
was so grateful and I know that people
people are feeling like I let them down
she admitted that she used to feel like
quote I let myself and everyone down too
but holds faith that there's more coming
for her I know that everything happens
for a reason I know that this too shall
pass no matter what things may look like
right now she added that her grandmother
who knows absolutely nothing about the
music industry is her main guidance and
support system all she knows is how to
listen and call out a good singer when
she hears one we didn't know what to do
with the win especially being that we
had absolutely no help there are people
who have had more success than me and
good for them I'm happy for them but I
am not them I don't like my situation
but it won't be like this forever
so she had previously opened up via
Instagram stories about how she ended up
broke after parting ways with Hollywood
Records after the show she said I'm
making music I just cannot afford to
release music because mixing and
mastering music costs a lot of money and
I invested in myself and ended up broke
that's the truth not broke broke like
I'm living I have my own place
um she revealed that she left the label
that signed her after she won American
Idol before releasing an album and owed
money to the company she said quote I'm
not even going to tell you guys the
amount of money that I had to pay after
leaving the label to claim songs that I
had already recorded yeah no record
labels are like actual prisons
especially when you sign a contract from
winning a uh right you're you're so
vulnerable you know nothing you I think
like
American Idol has a like a deal with a
certain record label so you don't have
options you're not going to go take the
best offer no and it's not like the
language in the contract is going to be
so beneficial yeah that's with every
competition show like they have all
these things that you win at the end but
they are extremely constricting yeah and
so I guess that she had disagreements
with her record label and like decided
to go out on her own which to break a
contract is very expensive and if you
don't have all those contacts and
know-how of the music industry you kind
of could be stranded yeah and so up
until this point like it it hasn't
worked out yet but I like that she holds
faith that it will and I think a lot of
people this story broke like today
um in like the news even though she had
posted it on Instagram
um I think a lot of people are really
wanting to support yeah and feeling
really in her corner so I hope that this
Garners her some more momentum and also
like winning a season of American Idol I
don't know how much you know momentum
that gives you
but also in the middle of co-ed like a
virtual I remember I actually watched it
a virtual like finale
it's just not it's not giving what it
needs to give no it's not giving Kelly
Clarkson 40 million views right right so
I think there's a lot of things that
we're working against her but I think in
terms of the financial situation having
to reach your contract and pay back
whatever your Advance was and then maybe
and then some because of your you're
bridging a contract is gonna is gonna
you financially yeah but that's
really sad I also I just don't know
how much success like this thing with
Ian tongi right now is so unprecedented
American Idol nobody has cared about the
winner of American Idol that's much like
since Kelly Clarkson like it's not it's
unprecedented for like the last five
years you know what I mean since the
show has come back
since the show has come back agreed so I
don't know if this would have happened
regardless
like I don't think this will happen to
him tongi because the the virality like
people care like I said they were
talking about him on Joe Rogan it's it's
kind of
a big deal but in Seasons past I don't
know that the winner of Gabby Barrett's
season like I could not tell you where
that person is
so I don't know if this is American Idol
thing if it's a Sam thing you know I
think it's oh all of the things like I
think it could be said for American Idol
and the voice I don't know what happens
over at America's Got Talent but like
all these shows they have it's really
exciting when you're on it they have
really big prize money money and stuff
and so it's worth winning but it doesn't
necessarily set you up for a career no
and I feel like they've actually kind of
given up on it even pretending to yeah
you know so it's like you can get some
really great things out of it make
connections it's it's a step it's not as
many it's not a whole last staircase
like it used to be yeah no it's exactly
so then also I think breaking with your
record label and I'm sure she had very
legitimate reasons but that is like if
you're starting from then you're taking
you're starting from square one again
it's expensive so I think it's a
combination and then also being on
probably the lowest rated season covet
covid right
yeah it's all the elements working
against but it's just it's interesting
to see where these shows which used to
hold so much power were they net out
because every now and then like now we
have a gabby Barrett or we have uh like
someone from The Voice I feel like
recently I mean Morgan Wallen was on The
Voice yeah although he really does not
attribute any of his success no I don't
think any of his successes because of
the voice I think it's a coincidence I
think and maybe he even feels the
opposite like it's you know a stain
right like it worked against him yeah
um
it's just interesting because like we
grew up where like if you even made it
to the top four Jennifer Hudson didn't
even win she's an Oscar Catherine McPhee
Catherine V Daughtry
Lauren Elena she didn't even win number
two Scotty McCreery did and I would say
she's more famous than Scotty McCreery
tons of circles you run in yeah but it's
just it's interesting because it used to
be this like golden platform where if
you got to a certain point like you were
okay you didn't have to win and now it's
like you could win and nobody gives a
yeah no it's like if you're in the
subway and you hear someone singing
amazing you're like you're so good you
should want American Idol but that
doesn't mean your life is going to
change you could go on American Idol win
it and still be back where you started
exactly
it's weird yeah I guess like social
media is the new American Idol
yeah no it's not and that's why it's
like it's not like I expect anyone who
wins American Idol to really become the
America the idol of America but there's
perks yeah yeah there's prize money
right
I don't know it's just a record deal I
don't think there is I think on
America's Got Talent there's like a
million dollar prize I don't think on
American Idol on The Voice do actually
win money you win like you just win got
it or you like win a contract that's
worth so much right right it's like
America's Next Top Model right right
when a hundred thousand dollars contract
with Covergirl yeah right right right
yeah interesting yeah are you ready for
our fifth and final story I really am
it's some good news for the grads for
the congrats congrats grads because now
you can get a free Krispy Kreme donut
this week Martha you're in debt but you
get a donut high school and college
grads who we are congratulating can head
to Krispy Kreme for a dozen free
original glazed donuts you know what I'm
graduating this week I think I need a
donut a dozen free donuts a dozen let me
tell you why I love talking about I just
want to say I love Krispy Kreme best
donut on Earth don't even try to make
one right but they will look for any
excuse Market a free donut yeah you got
your vaccine come get a donut they
literally and you know what we're always
talking about them it's always working
yeah oh but that's just yeah that's I
think that's an us thing yeah I know the
reason why we kind of let's just be like
really transparent because we're so
authentic the reason why if there's like
even the smallest news story about
Krispy Kreme the reason why we'll always
talk about it is because we're fat yeah
well duh thus leading me to my
explanation which is more often than not
the crispy Kreme PR team reaches out
it's like let us send some donuts to the
studio I'm the one who chooses the
stories and it's not why I do
I just think it's like oh people who are
watching this if you graduated this week
like go get your ass no no actually I
did a meet and greet yesterday and there
were so many girls who had just
graduated girlies run to Krispy Kreme
yeah I love Krispy Kreme no it's
so good it's so good it's so
uncomplicated you know it's just a
simple dessert but you have to be decked
out in class of 2023 of power oh that's
two million to score a dozen original
glazed donuts from bakery chain no
purchase necessary we need to make 2023
merch so everyone I think I still have
like my robe and gown somewhere but I
think it needs to say 2023 whether it be
a school t-shirt or a full graduation
cap and gown students dress that their
academic Garb can earn their baked goods
in a special diploma diploma wrapped you
know they paid like a creative agency
600 000 to come up with diploma you know
what
it's pretty good no we could come up
with something better no we couldn't
we couldn't
no we couldn't we couldn't
um okay so not me running home to my
childhood bedroom to look for my cap and
gown
or do you know a grad
I just like want a donut this
conversation is making me like
insatiably hungry okay well it's good
that that's our fifth Story because
we're closer to lunch we are closer to
lunch and if you graduated this week
congrats right
congrats grads you know I feel like
graduating college like is it is an
accomplishment but it's kind of like a
terrible time in your life because like
you're really entering the real world
and all the responsibilities that come
along with it you're moving out of like
your comfortable dorm or sorority house
and you're moving into the real world
and and donuts help so that's really
thoughtful yeah it is really fun like
postgrad is like I think a time that a
lot of people romanticized but it's
really like a terrible time it's doesn't
have to be but I feel like it definitely
can be there so often than not it's like
not what you expect things in place in
college that make you feel like an adult
but they're actually like propping you
up completely and then you come out into
the real world and it's just like what
do I eat for breakfast lunch and dinner
you know so I how do I pay for this
breakfast lunch and dinner right I could
understand like it's not all it's
cracked up to me but it's also a time of
real like growth growth and actual
adulthood opportunity and you know you
don't have to go to classes you don't
have to write papers like there's no no
like the day the day I left like the
last homework assignment I ever did like
was it a moment I will never forget like
I'm not one of those people who seeks
higher education like I quite literally
hated writing papers like any form of
homework it's not was not my strong suit
that was exciting for me but some people
were like really successful at stuff
like that and then they get to the real
world and they don't have those accounts
don't apply because they don't
mean anything yeah great you can write a
paper go sit at your desk and crunch
some numbers like it really so much of
what you are trained to like be good at
in college ends up really providing no
value in the real world unless you're a
writer or unless you're uh but even so
even if you're a writer like right when
you graduate you're not getting like the
big job right you're getting coffee but
you know how to write because of the
writing courses yeah
like it's just
it's it's depend person to person but by
the time I graduated college like I was
ready to go and I was excited for what
the future had in store for me but I'm
also a girly who likes change yes you
know you are
um all right so those were the past five
and how would you categorize them
amazing honestly like productive
conversations were had solving the
crisis of American Idol Katy Perry
should be meaner
end of story end of story so the show is
not over the show is not over I know you
thought it was you're sitting here oh no
what am I going to do it's not over
thank God thank God because it's
Wednesday so that means Our advice
segment which is called deer toasters we
do every Wednesday if you want to write
in it's dear toasters gmail.com we'll of
course keep your name and identity
completely Anonymous but if you're
having any trouble at work wedding
planning girlfriends dating we're gonna
do our best to help you and if we have
done our best to help you in the past
and you took our advice or didn't take
our advice but there was like an update
please don't leave the girls hanging
like let us know we actually have an
update today which I teased previously
and I'm really excited about it so I'm
gonna go in with our first semicion
hey Jackson turning my best friend tried
to get me to listen to you for at least
a year before I actually did shout out
to the stubborn girlies but now I can't
get enough here's my dilemma I don't
really need direct advice but I'm
looking for more opinions I've always
had a really large chest and I've
recently started the process of a breast
reduction at a surgeon consultation I
went to physical therapy so we could get
covered by Insurance I've also in recent
years gained weight which has obviously
not helped my large chest situation I'm
really nervous at getting a breast
reduction will somehow make my weight
gain more apparent because I won't be
able to hide behind my 38 G's what think
oh interesting there is definitely like
a push and pull a dynamic between weight
and breasts and breasts and for me
um I always felt that my breasts made me
look bigger
but I don't know what I would have
looked like with small breasts like
maybe I just would have looked bigger
yeah I do think that breast can often
make you look bigger than you are I
think sometimes people think like
proportion like if this is break then
that makes that look small but it just
depends on your body shape like your
size there are so many factors at play
um
and so I wouldn't get a breast reduction
with the idea of looking skinnier right
that I because it could go either way
like and that's not really the point
yeah so I'm I'm very supportive and
understanding of a breast reduction like
literally so excited I hope to have one
one day like send your doctor's info
um but it has to be like the right time
and for the right reasons and also like
a lot of times when you gain weight you
gain weight in your boobs they get
bigger and then you lose weight and they
get smaller so if you really are want to
work on like your whole self like maybe
losing weight would solve the problem of
your big breasts and then also you
wouldn't have this fear that they might
it might like throw your shape off right
or it might grow back like some people
just inherently have big breasts like I
was having this conversation at brunch
or maybe after brunch this weekend which
is like my pant size and my dress size
has changed so drastically I've actually
bought bigger bras my breast size has
not changed in the slightest so I
thought maybe my boobs were always so
big like my whole life because I've
always been chubby and overweight but
actually I and I could have guessed that
because everyone in our family has huge
tits we are just a big breasted family
so some people are inherently like just
gifted with big breasts or cursed
depending on how you look at it some
people are just born with big breasts
and some people have big breasts because
of weight gain so I think it's important
to understand like you might get a
breast reduction but if your boobs were
boobs because of weight gain and you
then gain more weight your boobs like
we're back yeah like it's so important
to know your body and like your boobs
and like for me how why do you have big
boobs are you born with them
I know every time I gain weight I my
boobs get bigger and when I like I've
gained in weight lost weight over the
years many times and when I lose weight
my boobs don't get smaller so there is
like they just keep getting bigger but
they don't get smaller and it's like
it's really annoying yeah but me
and if that's the case for you then get
a breast reduction regardless because
they're staying big right down is down
but if it's overall like you've gained
weight and you want your breasts to be
smaller but then you still are going to
have like insecurity issues in other
areas if you're probably like maybe try
losing weight first and see if that
changes your boobs yeah or like are you
getting the breast reduction because
driving back problems like the normal
things then it's worth pursuing I don't
know I I find I I when I thought about a
breast reduction but I plan on I'm
getting one it's on my list of things to
do but I plan on waiting I don't know if
I ever really con factored in my weight
and I don't think I ever thought about
it because my boobs just bothered me so
much and like now that you've lost
weight like
wouldn't you like now it wouldn't have
made sense for you to get a breast
reduction like before this time why
because what do you want them to like
suit how you are now like what no I
think I would have asked for the same
size no matter what no matter what size
I agree with that like I have an ideal
breast size and no matter how much I
weigh that doesn't change
yeah I would just say you can always get
a breast reduction like you could that
can always be a solution I would try
some other things first to see if that
makes you happier with your overall look
because if it doesn't you could always
just get a breast reduction right but
you can't undo it unless you're having
like a lot of other problems because of
the breasts like and they're bothering
you so much like if you're just getting
them
to look smaller yeah as opposed to like
having back problems or everyone talks
about these back problems but I have had
big tits forever and I don't have well
just consider yourself extremely lucky
you don't have it either I have terrible
back problems but PT said it wasn't from
your boobs I know but Frank said I'm not
buying that like I'm really not I'm
genuinely not
but most people who have big breasts on
small frames or like frames that really
can't like sustain it
suffer immensely like on a daily basis
did you say that no but but she didn't
bring it up so I'm just wondering if if
that was the reason for the restaurant I
don't think it is okay
I'm just wondering what the reason was
I'm just saying you could always go and
get a breast reduction
so don't make it be your first choice
yeah but I fully support when and I
always support I support it the concept
can't wait for you I have a resurrection
um all right we have one more submission
and then we have our update which are
both brought to you by Topgolf it's golf
it's not golf Jax
it's Topgolf very good very good
um and they have half price Tuesdays at
Topgolf that I feel like more people
need to be talking about so at Topgolf
they of course have the things that make
it golf they've got the clubs balls
teas whatever all that stuff but they
also have a bunch of stuff that's not
golf related like great music huge
Targets in the Fairway delicious food a
handcrafted food and beverage menu and
they even have a whole day each week
dedicated to more play For Less pay so
they do this thing on Tuesday where all
game is half price giving players even
more reason to come play around
so we visited Topgolf in Nashville very
recently Without You Jax but also a year
before that with you and we had a great
time both times the first time we went
it was a girls trip and I don't think
any of us expected to have as much fun
as we did but we had such great food
great cocktails we also really like got
into the golf which was shocking but we
had the best time what else was shocking
that you won
um every time we do a read like you have
to write I just feel like they wanted us
to talk about our experience there and
that's your main to the experience that
I won but our experience was the best in
Nashville like a month ago when we all
came with our husbands was so much fun
like it got even more competitive and
the boys loved it it was a perfect thing
for like a couple's night out but it
really was just as fun just us girls
um mostly because the food is so good
um half price Tuesday applies to
gameplay only it's not offered at every
venue but it can be doubled up with
offers or discounts
um it's really just a great way to spend
your night if you have a top golf in
your area or if you're planning a trip
where there is a Topgolf
check it out it's really fun it's golf
it's not golf
okay our next admission
hey Jackson turdy nope that's the one we
just did sorry hey Jackson turd I'm
getting married in a few weeks and I'm
having a big issue with my mother-in-law
she is adamant about wanting to walk my
fiance down the aisle
kind of like the father walks the
daughter I've consistently told her no
as my fiance she'd have his own moment
coming down and she can be walked down
the aisle by her husband who is also the
best man but she is constantly going
behind my back to my fiance to try and
get her way am I being an Aggie
wife or is this annoying well we come at
this from a very unique perspective
because in Jewish weddings the parents
both mother and father walk down both
the groom and the bride so to me there's
nothing out of the ordinary for this but
I think in traditional weddings taking
that out of it like you're not even
gonna see your husband walk down the
aisle and with his mom without his mom I
would like imma pick your battle sort of
girl and this is just not one worth
waging like if she want if it's up to
your husband like well that was my
question if he doesn't want his mom to
walk him down then that's up for him to
say and you're out of it and if he
doesn't mind then it would make his mom
really happy you're literally not even
gonna see it who cares yeah no my um
question was how does your husband
fiance feel if he's down why do you care
if he's not down then like he should
stand up for himself yeah but this is
like one of those wedding decisions that
quite has nothing to do with you and in
the end like I don't think you'll really
care about she won't even know she's in
the back getting ready for a big walk
it's possible like I'm just getting the
vibe that you just like dislike your
mother-in-law and like everything she
does bothers you which like that I I
understand who people who have that
situation like it's very I'm not
discounting your feelings
um but that's why you wrote in for a
perspective and I just want you yeah it
was a third party like we have nothing
to do with this like you do sound like a
little like Naggy no not not and
not nbw not NBF Mega fiance but
just like you're getting too invested in
decisions big and small and and some
that have literally nothing to do with
you like this is maybe like the one
moment of the whole wedding that's not
about you enjoy that and you'll be in
the back with a glass of champagne
waiting for your turn who cares what
happens before you right the mother's
gonna forget the minute you walk in like
and even if they remember that the
mother walks the sun down
I don't think it's that crazy like
honestly if he wants to do it like
obviously he has a good relationship
with his mom like I don't know I have no
problem with this I have no problem and
just as like an outsider it will take
nothing away from you like it's not like
her walking down it's gonna be like oh
taking all the you know Spotlight away
no one's even gonna be looking at her
because it's really not about her it's
about her son so there's no downside to
this and if you like die on this hill
which if you feel really strongly that
then die on it but you're gonna look a
little
like a little bit like a like
honestly no it's just so not worth dying
over and is that worth starting off the
in-law relationship like on this note no
it's like I've never really been so
Crystal Clear on the deer toasters a
hundred percent let it go it's your
husband's Choice yeah and you know what
it's so nice to not have to make a
choice sometimes this is his problem oh
it's up to you sweetie yeah you talk to
your mother about it so you guys figure
it out it's your moment godspeed it's
not about me no I have to go how
terrible I'm so busy with other
important decisions that actually
involve me and because I gave you this
by the way I'm getting the flowers I
want right right yeah no like it's
really not a big deal no
all right now we're long awaited Let It
Go Let It Go no Let Her Go Let Her Go I
feel like at one point we used to try
and come up with a song for each deer
too which is kind of like amazing okay
let's go back to the other one the other
one was about the boobs
she works hard for the boobies
[Music]
she wakes her for the boobies but she's
gotta let them down that was good that
is good that little riff I did was like
kind of stunning
um okay ready for our big click bait
update it better be good okay hey ladies
no by the way it is good I think there's
a lesson to be learned okay first off I
want to say thank you for the beautiful
stunning and smart queens that you are
and you make my mornings fabulous
Claudia I loved your book congrats
congrats I heard she wrote she was just
upset there was no acknowledgments at
the back of the book no sorry I read the
wrong thing that was her initial
um submission but I'm just gonna recap
the whole thing for you okay okay great
first off I want to say thank you for
the amount of joy that the toast brings
me each and every day it's such a bright
light in my life and has helped me make
friends keep in touch with loved ones
and always guarantees me an hour of Joy
No Matter What so thank you sending you
both love oh my God what a great recap
so I'm here with the update I was the 25
year old virgin who wrote in two years
ago Chelsea Handler helped give me
advice and she told me just to lose it
to someone and get it over with you two
told me to wait for the right man then
in early 2022 I wrote in again about a
guy who dumped me because he felt like
taking my virginity was too much
pressure I really thought I would never
find the right guy but you both helped
me realize what a loser he was and
reassured me that the right man would
not care
I decided to believe you and I trusted
that I chose to stop putting so much
pressure on it and to truly believe it
would happen for me at the right time
sure enough about a month later the
right guy came along he never batted an
eye about me being a virgin and actually
found it incredibly respectable he never
pressured me and always took things at
the pace I wanted suffice to say I'm no
longer writing in as a virgin truly it
was everything I could have asked for
writing into other girls who may be in
the same boat don't lose hope there are
men out there who aren't losers don't
give up or settle best always signed a
no longer RDH virgin
so what she's what she's saying is
Chelsea Handler's advice was not the
right way to go and ours was it's not
the right course of action for her and
it's a great lesson I like the moral of
the story there are men out there who
are not losers who have like good values
and will respect a girl who chooses
abstinence for whatever reason be it
religious or or otherwise yes I was so
thrilled to hear that our girl is a
getting railed which is just fabulous by
a respectable King who respects her and
her body who took it slow I don't I do
give a rail right now
I was thrilled to hear that I obviously
like love to hear that she took our
advice over Chelsea's like what's better
than that you know pitting women against
each other and three I'm just so happy
like you know the lesson here is like
you know I think it can feel in this
culture yeah like men are just the
worse and disgusting and they
are and for the most time I also feel
like you know with like that all women
have to have the same attitude towards
sex and and it's great to be liberated
but we're not all the same and we all
feel differently about it so I can
understand feeling pressure and I feel
like I should just get rid of it yeah
like and I feel like I've been in that
situation before where it's like am I
making this a bigger deal than it is is
it really a big deal I've like always
thought it was a big deal like and
questioning everything like you once
thought and I think it's okay for all of
us to feel differently about it right
and I think it's very empowering to have
the other sort of opinion on virginity
which is like yes sex is freedom
whatever it's great I think it's great
but I don't think you get spoken about
enough I think in culture like it's a
perfect example even though like he
ended up being a virgin who was gay but
Colton like he was really mocked for
being a virgin and and I think on The
Bachelor like in culture like it's a
thing that's mocked but it is it is
ultimately a nice respectable letter to
not be to not care and whatever
um but there's something to be said
about that life and that route and I
think it's wonderful and this is a
perfect example I think it's cool of it
working out and you protected something
and then you found someone who respected
that and I just think it's great I'm so
happy for you and it's also a lesson
that like there are good guys out there
and they're very hard to find and so
don't give up and be true to you because
she rode into us in 2022 it's a year two
you know Chelsea was on like it was
coveted
oh wait I think she wrote the year hold
on she said two years ago I think your
book had just come out that's why she
was talking about it yeah you're right
and then she wrote in again A year later
so it's been a two-year Saga but she
never gave up beautiful I think that's
fabulous a gorgeous lesson and a
gorgeous way to end this Wednesday show
agreed I'm so excited do you have a song
for her oh
Like a Virgin
for the very first time like a virgin
with your heartbeats next to mine
I think it's nice or I got another one
white houses that songs about losing
your virginity so true in my heart but
it's kind of about like traumatizing
it's not a good way to go yeah oh I got
another one I got another one for her I
could do this all day Let's Get It On
children
I'd like your first one best okay great
for the situation there's not really a
song about like losing virginity in like
a sacred way
I guess it would be like a virgin does
Taylor have a song
that's the big question yep it comes
back to who did Taylor lose her
virginity right it's either living for
the thrill of hitting you where it
hurts give me back my girl hood it was
mine first
[Music]
my old scarf from that very first week
cause it reminds you of innocence and it
smells like me you can't get rid of it
cause you remember it all too well
so whichever song resonates with you
dear reader
both are kind of like negative
experiences yeah no so still Madonna but
it was fun to think it was any excuse
and I got it so low so tomorrow is our
last episode of the week we will be in
studio being girls swirly tour lace
hopefully no promises you know we never
know but if I'm feeling clickbaity I'm
thinking we're gonna be girls I think so
I think we have some bombshell news to
drop tomorrow that you can only catch
here on the on the toast oh actually we
are going to do something tomorrow yeah
I know so you actually should tune in
yeah we are you should yeah so thank you
guys so much for listening to the toast
the Millennium Morning Show where we
deliver the past five stories you need
to know every Monday through Friday on
YouTube so if you're watching this on
YouTube please don't forget to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as a podcast anywhere
podcasting we found so at Spotify iTunes
schedule a public video I heard of
castbox all the places webless and
podcasts find us the toes leave me five
star review about a beautiful stunning
and wickedly talented we are hope you
guys have an amazing day happy hump day
and we'll see you tomorrow love you bye